Here we can see a very small data set
that could have come from a survey.
We can see where each record, also known
in statistical speak as an observation,
has a number assigned
to the survey taker,
as well as how they responded to
various questions in the survey.
For whatever reasons,
some of the records or
observations are missing some data.
We can see from the data here that
they're basically just blank or
empty cells.
However, depending on where the data
is coming from, maybe a database,
a CSV, or Excel file, this missing
data may take on different forms.
For example, if the data comes
from a CSV file, it might look
just like it does in our initial screen
where the missing data is just blank.
However, if the data
comes from a database,
you might actually see it
represented as a null value.
That's database speak for
it doesn't know what the value is.
Another way we might see missing data
represented could be as a value N/A,
which typically means not
available in programs that we use.
But regardless of how it appears,
we still need to deal with the fact
that we have values in our
data set that are missing.